in the evening so so today we'll go over
one of my games actually played right
here in the Chess Club I like showing
games that I played at the club actually
I have since I have lots of games and
I'll be playing all the US Championships
here since 2009 and I found this game
that I thought might be interesting to
show you today and this is from a 2013
US Championship and I'm playing with the
white pieces here and my opponent at
that time was very young but strong
international master Kaden trough who is
of course a strong Grandmaster now and
played a couple of times in the US
Championships if he was I believe he was
a u.s. junior as well and finished
second in last year your junior
champions or so so my opponent very
strong talented Kaden trough it's always
tough when you play this young
up-and-coming players because you don't
really know exactly their strengths they
could be like 24 21 like here it shows
but they could be playing at least 25 21
strings so you really don't know what
you're getting into so you always have
to be careful that's why I'm you know
very careful extra because when I'm
playing
26:51 masters you know at the certain
age I I know that this is you know where
his strength is but when you play the
young players you don't know it could be
really really underrated so you have to
be a little bit careful so the opening
was no surprise Kaden is a grünfeld
player and I you know was expecting he
will play this so and we have this
opening the groom fell defense at this
moment we don't know the name wood
opening yet because it could be a groom
felt as you see with default but it
could be another additional opening
which opening it could be in addition to
the groom felt here if he plays this
move if he plays this move Bishop to g7
what's the name of this opening
the Kings Indian defense it would be
okay so that's why we don't know yet but
you play the move d5 so now after we see
the move d5 we know that we have the
groom field defense one of the toughest
openings against d4 to get any advantage
Grunwald is very tough it's so many
different lines so many different ideas
but it's just quite tough to get
anything against it so I played almost
all the systems against it I'm still
jumping from one system to another
nowadays you know and it seems like a
lot of my opponents target this opening
day you know they see that I have always
different systems so they try against me
to play groom fault so I play Knight f3
and Bishop g7 and at that time this one
was just getting popular this h4 move
it's kind of all the old news nowadays
you know but five years ago it was very
very interesting very popular and
challenging okay challenging against the
groom for so the idea of this h4 movies
after at the moment at some point I want
to take and when he takes back I played
the move h5 and then I have a pawn
putting pressure on g6 I have some h6
ideas so I'm trying to play this move h5
at the right moment so that's the idea
behind it
Kaden reacted c6 is one of the most
solid ways to play against the system
when world champion Magnus Carlsen was
facing this he also played a mostly six
so very very solid opening choice the
more sharper lines are take E 4 C 5 D 5
D 5 and it leads to a really sharp
complicated position I play this a few
times another alternative is castle and
that leads to this position after C D in
95 h5 c5
take take Bishop h6 okay I did this
position as well again very interesting
why this perhaps slightly better here
okay but not so easy to mate here so if
you get the Queen only two years you're
gonna meet but it's not so easy
alright so Keaton played c6 so what this
move does is now he basically every time
I take he's just gonna take back with a
pawn he's not gonna move the knight from
f6 so he says you know what you're not
really gonna get this h5 in that easily
you're not gonna get this in that easily
so you should g5 I played to put
pressure Queen b6 this one was a little
bit of a surprise I knew the move CC for
Queen b6 he was a little surprised he
played it I think relatively quickly so
he perhaps analyze this little bit you
know it was very very fashionable he
probably wasn't expecting that I would
play this but he maybe he prepared for
the tournament and had some ideas Queen
b6 putting pressure on beat you okay
what to do now the pawn is under attack
and you never really want to play the
move b3 here
b3 just weakens the position too much so
I played sorry
this yeah so I play the move Bishop
takes f6 okay
and I cannot play let's say Queen c2
because it's gonna be a problem because
of which move Bishop f5 hitting the
Queen with a Tempe I cannot play Queen
d2 because that's gonna be also attacked
by Knight e4 attacking the Queen perfect
so it's a Bishop f6 Bishop takes f6
because now I can play the move Queen d2
be dad worrying about Knight e4 jumping
in very specific play I'm giving up my
bishop but now I protected beat you I'm
threatening to take on d5 as well and so
he has to do something neither he has to
play ecigs protect or do something but
if you place is six I cannot play E for
attack the bishop
if the bishop goes back here he's not
gonna be too happy about ninety six
check and if he goes back to e seven you
can play see if I have attacking that
Queen he drives back bishops before I
think this is very pleasant
or perhaps even h5 I can play I have a
very nice active position good
development as well okay
so if I Bishop g7 if you play special
sin I have 96 thank you okay so he
played D takes c4 says you know what I
don't like the e6 let me take a pawn
here so what move you think I have in
mind to do against this and to to to
justify the fact that I give up my
Bishop what can I do what would you do
here before
excellent move yes II for gaining the
control of the center and getting ready
to capture the pawn back on c4 okay
nice control of the center and picking
up the pollen c4 but Kaden goes Bishop
e6 he says not so easy you're not
getting that pawn back that easily ow
I'm stuck I'm down upon and he has the
pair of the bishops he's got two bishops
and extra pawn here what should I do
d5 but then we opening up the monster
bishop here right he takes you're gonna
get the pawn back but the cost the cost
might be the cost might be too high yeah
take with the night here yes tix then
there's some problems here b2 is
dropping so in general when you open up
the diagonal it's risky you know very
risky yes please raise raise your hands
if you have the move yes well we have
the correct move by a young players aged
5 I'm taking advantage of the fact that
is not cancelled yet and I'm trying to
create some complications okay
now he took interesting yeah just he's
just not afraid at all now he takes and
he says you know what nama have two puns
two puns now I'm not sure he had this
move that's definitely interesting so we
have to do something we can't just let
him have everything yeah
I can't take a drop but I want a castle
I want to get the safety of my king that
pawn is gonna be mine now upon it's not
going anywhere I want to get the safety
and the possibilities to move my queen
if needed you know why I did this
because when he plays them of 97 I want
to try push attacking the bishop bishop
goes back I want to get up here attack
this guy okay
and now this bishop is very hard to
protect if you bring the rook over I can
take on h5 I mean this is where I was
aiming for okay
he plays h6 bit odd-looking move but you
know what he is trying to prevent now
correct he is trying to prevent my Queen
jump my Queen jump on g5 this is what he
is trying to prevent but this is time
this takes time and now I feel like I
have some ideas here age sex was
probably not the best move huh goes back
to g7
correct move he develops though he still
got the pair of the bishops okay and
still has he have the extra pawns - yeah
he does
of course sometimes you have to play
simple they give you pawns you take the
pawns
okay but in reality he was really afraid
of this line guys this it looks it looks
like really bad what he did but it's
very annoying this Queen g5 what are you
gonna do with the bishop you know eight
yes yes I agree but then takes and now
this h7 is hanging how do we protect the
Cena you feel the initiative initiative
is on white side it bishop f8 but okay
then if opponent has to go Bishop f8
that means success yeah if we force him
to go back from the develop square to
backwards that should be success I think
the worry guys think
your fate in a line of fire you know
very danger king of faith I'm not sure
about it okay
h6 well he's got he's got a knight there
so so with maybe 96 he can play I don't
know
no but he's worried about a 525 so I put
him in a situation where it was quite
confusing for him I think this is kind
of hard to play even right now all of us
are looking it's not so clear how black
should play of course computer will show
you but again it's very important to
understand when you analyzing or looking
at games with a computer it's just
completely different then actually when
you're playing the games you have no
idea what what's the best move what you
look for
so probably h6 wasn't the best move it's
at 896 it takes takes he castles but now
he's castled he's got the two bishops
he's got my d4 pawn hanging yeah I got
his Knight on the on the rim there but I
do need to worry about the center palm
it's the thing I got double pawns
excellent thinking yeah and the c4 pawn
is a little bit weak right it constantly
needs protection so but now it's we have
to play this correctly we have to play
this precisely okay here it worked out
great this this worked out great for me
this this game
right now he's got a threat he wants to
just take take and take
that's what he wants to do he's got
three attackers on my d4 and I've got
only two defenders he five I don't think
I play d5 if I play e5 he can just maybe
go back even Bishop h8 that's what I
play a queen III just defending my
center and keeping everything protected
his knight on a six looks a bit awkward
no and it's not so easy for him to to
show what he's gonna do next so Queen a5
plate again he's got the two bishops be
careful don't just open up the position
because if you open up the position it's
better for who the guy who has the two
bishops the player who has the two
bishops wants you to open up the
position okay the screen is very active
here it's super active here putting
pressure here it's guarding some
important things here so night before is
out there I gotta be careful okay
yes II five um I will get to the e5 okay
but first he wants to go night before do
we want to allow him to play night
before or we want to prevent that huh we
don't want him right so then we can have
to do what kind of moving it to prevent
that preventing move prophylaxis yes
prophylaxis yeah preventing of
preventing now he goes back to b6 yet
this was already but again he didn't
feel very comfortable here I think he
you should have played some Bishop g4 or
something I remember but yes so in I
goes Queen b6 now he goes Queen b6 he
puts pressure on d4 on b2 so it's
putting a little bit of pressure
perhaps mission trip or perhaps Bishop
c4 yeah get some activities going okay
now what do we do how should be played
at night on a6 is certainly misplaced
9595 be careful that night is the
defender right again what do you think
of yes your question actually
have you finished your development
Bishop is not developed that means your
Roop is not in a game as well right and
what we need to do to have a successful
game complete development which Peter
Bishop g7 because he sees that if I was
coming and he wants to have the Bishop
on g7 with some Bishop h6 ideas at some
point there is a rook can go now to h1
yeah and also yeah it's develop all this
is good to develop the pieces just
remember even if you think it's not
gonna do much but it's if it's developed
it's gonna protect more if it's not
developed it's not gonna protect more
yeah but it does something the bishop
here protects my knight protects my roof
protects okay all right so now again
what kind of move it feels like we need
here he's got that Bishop h6 always
looming there you know sitting there and
always threatening some push page six
looming ideas okay there we go
another prophylaxis prophylaxis now it
was Quimby tree trying to come in and
very threatening you know very
threatening jumping in now you could pay
look each one but ultimately we need to
get rid of this bishop on e6 right and
the night goes on g5 attacks that Bishop
any paid 9c server here try to remember
what happens if he plays Bishop here
so I think this [ __ ] page six maybe
would have been his best try to at least
keep the night paint I think I was gonna
play F for him gotta pee
yeah he's got the peanut fortunately so
I probably just play a four and taketake
play disposition perhaps it should be a
little bit better for white anyway yeah
it is an option I was thinking about
that actually we just got to make sure
that this line works yeah I don't know
this
probably good for a white yeah a four or
five I don't know
no this could have happened sub saw a
sideline now looks good for white yeah
okay so you played 97
now now this was a bad mode this 97 is
bedroom for sure how how or why well but
he's thinking if I take he was take back
for the night yeah
otherwise if I take he's gonna take back
with a pawn so he does he wants to take
that for the night excellent
takes and now it looks like he's got
three attackers on me three attackers on
me here what should I do here against
the three attackers absolutely let's pin
him and now he cannot take on d4 because
that night it's not an attacker anymore
it's a pinned piece so he goes through
36
now it's just really really tough
position for him of course of course it
is they should be for maybe no 25 Bishop
D for take Bishop d4
well let's shut down the bishop first
okay and now
now the bishop is shut down okay now
maybe we can do something active maybe
but I like that I like the quiet move f7
is very important target here right
because if you will have so many giving
so much here so why buy the quiet move
about a quiet move Queen f3
Kim b8
again d4 is hanging so take take and now
I have a fork
look at that Bishop that bishop is not
going to be a good Bishop fork Queen g4
bishop f8 look at that bishop I'm coming
back into the game no counter play now
d4 is hanging
let's get another pawn now and solidify
the position fish page six
g3 control right control the position a
six therefore shut down the
communication c5 he's trying to do
something open the position or do
something you know what do you do
oh of course defies check he's trying to
win the g3 pawn I don't think we want to
get pinned I like win d3
I like wind III protect very calmly now
which piece wants to join in the action
but then he has some c4 ideas right so
let's get the look into the game rooks
they like open files right you get open
file yeah and now sure get rid of every
active piece should be crushed away now
so no active pieces look at that what do
you do now past
three four let's push a little bit now
it's trying to break open shut it down
of course the six Bishop e7 attacking
the rook now we learned that rooks
belong on a seventh rank as well they
like the open files but what's better
than open file for the rook the seven
trunk where he can attack things right
now he takes well if he goes back I go
Queenie four so he went here take with
the rook and the final move of the game
pretty much you could take the pawn
that's probably very good seven it's
very good how about this neat move when
you're ahead
you never afraid to trade there you go
and now he is forced to resign or trade
Queens yeah okay
it's made on b7 so he can have one check
here I go king h2 no more checks no
checks no anything and if he trades he's
just down a whole night yeah white would
win this position without Knight just
taking only six to connect the pass once
so he resigned and this was round number
three of the US Championship 2013 five
years ago okay so this is something for
you to know how to deal with the groom
failed defense something you know in
addition to what you play if you play d4
you know in addition something very
interesting to work on on this h4 idea
okay now we're going to do some
important tactical positions the first
do you have any questions about this
games
and all these tactics were going to do
are played by a world champions okay so
we'll start out with the first world
champion and and I want to ask you the
name for the first world champion
William William Stein it's will him
Stein it's and he was from a family of
very poor family and he was from and is
and his father had 13 children and he
was the world champion of the world and
he was the 13th child no no no he was
wore out no it's just now there is a
court about him that you know that Tina
the poor you know that you know it was
poor and you know but he made it
basically no I recommend you read about
him will him Stein is world champion
from 1886 to 1894 eight years william
Steinitz white to play and win so we
will do a different world champions so
you'll get to know all the champions I
mean now all today but first you please
don't say the moves if you have it raise
your hand and you must have the whole
thing not the glimpse of it not a little
bit of it the whole thing I want if you
want to know the name of his opponent
this opponent was the no-name then they
didn't have them
they it was so it's they put nn-no name
you know in all days not always they
knew the name of the opponent sometimes
they do though actually no I mean if he
played some of these big guys like zoo
cared or you know zoo cared Orton oh
okay I have two hands so far should be
more I think should be more no this is
not that difficult but it's very nice
three hands now
okay a minute I give you another minute
one more minute
because you always remember better when
you find the idea that's if I find
something I can remember better than I
just see something yeah for hands I have
five now okay in the back friend
deflecting the Queen we truck the HM you
have to have everything though right
everything to sacrifice you're correct
Bravo what about you same thing others
orders
so the idea called decoy deflection okay
decoy and deflection idea we use in this
one
William Steiners we're moving out to the
Second World Champion now I like to in
this way that you get to know the
champions so black sir white to move and
win and this is play by a world champion
number two and who knows the name no no
number two - long time ago no not yet
not yet
a man will last year okay and he was a
world champion for a very long time you
guys know that one of the longest
longest world champions okay if you had
to guess for how long you think he was a
world champion 27 huh whoo-hoo he did oh
yeah yeah yeah 2790 1894 guys 1894 to
1921 a man will last Kish win yeah they
say mate win uh actually this is not
even his game this is his study actually
he composed this himself
I'm seeing a hand I'm seeing a hand
but in more hands no one strong
participant let's see a monorail Alaska
so he defeated who to win the
championship
William Stein leads you down a piece
here and it looks like this Bishop is
extremely annoying you know so it looks
very very very very tough no it's white
to plan win I mean it looks like black
should when I agree but sometimes in
chess you think one side should win but
the other side wins you know it's it's
tough tough game it's your line
beautiful is it extraordinary one two
three all right I'm gonna give you the
chance try it it's him it's him this
time but Roxy a check I take first
things first first things first first
things first okay
well I got a background I got a
background mate guys you got a
protectable there you have it and there
you have it that's very important okay
got the Queen if Queen wasn't guarding
it black would have prevailed and if
you're taken back with the Queen then
Queenie one mates yes question
alright so I have to take no choice yes
Queen takes a seven sacrificing its who
so that raised your hand young player
yes on their promotion on the promotion
right guys you gotta remember the under
promotion go don't be too fixed on Queen
Queen promotion okay this idea is called
under promotion right you know under
promotion now you remember thank you
very much for the Queen and this
position should be no problem converting
okay just accurately accurately you move
okay around
they're about equal they're about equal
but I got two extra pounds here yeah if
you didn't have those two pounds you're
not gonna win this even if you have one
point you're not gonna win this
- you're likely to win it okay yeah this
is yeah this is winning okay and the
next one the last one for today okay
this you you're on will just win
immediately you just basically you bring
the night here the bishop moves you
start pushing the guys you know get your
king and stop pushing your pawns
okay you know you don't win immediate
but you win okay the next one one of my
most favorite world champions let's see
capablanca and I share the same birthday
with capablanca November 19 just so you
know same birthday with a world champion
and he was a third world champion for
six years 1921 to 1927 from Cuba of
course
and this is what last year said I have
known many chess players but only one
genius Capablanca that was saved by last
year okay okay he has many good tactics
many good tactics I'll do the most
famous one because I want to have a big
class here and a few of you might know
this one but I think would be nice for
everybody to know one of the most famous
games by capablanca kappa blanka white
Mona roof Fona roof new york white to
play and win let's see if you can play
like up a blanca here very famous most
one of most famous positions you have to
calculate four moves it's a form of
combination okay that wins the game for
you double check double check your
answer double check so make sure you
remember everything
nobody familiar with this position you
you familiar with this position or you
know it okay
all right wait I was gonna ask you all
right let's see here
no no hands hmm
well who okay one hand I see two ends we
see aha three hands we see okay
give you a chance first rook to d7 okay
and it takes the quid I take back sorry
that didn't work yeah but also I can
take your rook you know right I can't
take the rook and it's tricky okay f-for
here but it's not so forcing you know I
take yeah but not so clearly now it's
good for you but it's not like you're
winning you know you're not winning this
on the spot here all right
oh you're back you're back alright give
a chance here
sure check I can't take it right I have
to go here sacrificing the Queen
that's some serious tactics serious
calculation right there everybody thank
you for the Queen and if he takes what
do you do
check check
checkmate good job
very nice very nice do you get it now
alright let's do it again
that's how Capablanca one night h6 check
sock high-stakes check take this take
this
don't checkmate
yes no no it's a it's a faulty it's
faulty actually it's faulty he takes the
Queen and then you take check and look
like black turns the tables and
checkmate
he turns the tables it's great job
everybody okay great job see you on
Thursday
you
[Music]